oh
my parents are inviting us to the Summer
Place for the big Fourth of July weekend
I can't leave my father this is the
first summer since we have to say
goodbye to your dear Mother and you're
going to leave me to burn the spot
because alone
let's bring it nah I don't think so
you hear this ladies he's worried his
immigrified is going to make it look
like some kind of Goomba
if we're gonna do this Dad you gotta
dial it down
what is this wow
this is amazing my name is here it's
called love and affection then unlike
you when you met me at the delivery room
you chose to shake my hand what else was
I supposed to do we just met
him Sebastian I don't know how you're
gonna fit in yeah
don't these people have jobs they got
their money in the stock market that
mayonnaise jars buried in their backyard
I just hope nothing gets stolen this
weekend because these people love to
blame the immigrants
we'll give you the grant to work this is
Doug he's learning to be a Healer hello
what are you doing he's just serenading
our pet peacock
I love you these people are strange say
it burns for a place he's like
[Music]
he's like your [__] are just a bunch of
goddamn show-offs if you ask me
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you're gonna spend the whole
time embarrassing me how could you say
that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I can die I'm
trying to make sure that you don't make
an ass out of yourself by trying to be
somebody you're not
oh my gosh oh [__] Sebastian your suit
it's Versace do you like it no you [__]
it's not up
I would love to make a full Italian
dinner for everybody we don't keep a lot
of food here Maniscalco always finds a
way to feed his family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can't believe we put this
all together from what we have in the
kitchen it's artichoke and poultry
absolutely
[Music]
oh no
you slide up their pet peacock and you
thought I was crazy for worrying that
you were gonna make us look like some
bad Italian staff that's right to help
me get rid of the evidence why does it
seem like you've done this before